量子情報と計算の理解へようこそ。俺の名前はJohn Watusで、IBMの教育担当テクニカルディレクターだ。
Quantum。これはシリーズの第15レッスンで、量子誤り訂正を扱う第4ユニットの第3レッスンだ。
これまで、9-qubit Shoreコードを含む量子誤り訂正符号のいくつかの例を見てきた。
7-qubit Steaneコード、5-qubitコード、そしてこれらや他の多くの量子誤り訂正符号を記述・分析するための数学的基盤を提供するスタビライザー形式についても議論した。
これらの量子誤り訂正符号を記述・分析するための数学的基盤を提供してくれる。
今挙げたコードは間違いなく興味深く、探求を始めるのに自然な出発点となる。
量子誤り訂正の探求において。問題は、それらが非常に低い誤り率しか許容できないことだ。
5、7、9個のqubitのうち1個のqubitの誤りを訂正するのは悪くないが、おそらく少なくとも我々が疑っている限りでは、
大規模な量子コンピューティングを実現するためには、それよりずっと多くの誤りに対処できる必要があるだろう。
このレッスンでは、より洗練された量子誤り訂正符号の構成を初めて見ていく。それらは次のようなコードだ。
これまで見てきたものよりもはるかに高い誤り率を許容でき、実用的な量子誤り訂正の有望な候補として見られている。
実際の物理デバイスにおいて。レッスンの簡単な概要を示す。まず
CSSコードとして知られる量子誤り訂正符号のクラスから始める。これはそれを最初に発見した研究者たちの名前、Robert Calderbank、Peter
Shaw、Andrew Steaneにちなんで命名されている。CSSコードの構成は、特定の古典的符号のペアを
組み合わせて量子誤り訂正符号を作ることを可能にする。その議論の一部として、
古典的線形符号をざっと見ていき、CSSコードの基本的な特性についても話す。
レッスンの第2部は、トーリックコードとして知られるコードに関するもので、これは基本的で本当に
美しい量子誤り訂正符号の例であり、比較的高い誤り率に対処できる。実際、
トーリックコードは量子誤り訂正符号の単一の例ではなく、むしろ無限族のコードであり、
2から始まる各正の整数に対応している。レッスンの最後の部分では、他のいくつかの
量子コードの族について簡単に議論する。トーリックコードと密接に関連するsurface codesや
color codesなどだ。古典的誤り訂正符号は1940年代から研究されており、
魅力的で豊かな分野だ。線形符号はおそらく最もシンプルな古典的誤り
訂正符号の一種で、この文脈で「線形」という言葉が何を意味するかをすぐに正確に説明する。しかし、
それらが何であるかを表現するシンプルな方法は、たまたま古典的なスタビライザーコードであるということだ。そしてすぐに分かるように、
CSSコードは基本的に、量子誤り訂正符号を作るために組み合わされた古典的線形符号のペアだ。
したがって、その議論のために、古典的線形符号についていくつかの基本的なことを
理解する必要がある。まず、この議論全体でバイナリアルファベットをΣとする。
古典的線形符号とは、ある正の整数nに対して長さnのバイナリ文字列の集合Cを意味する。
これは1つの基本的な性質を満たす。uとvがCにあるバイナリ文字列であれば、
u XOR vもCにある。ちなみに、u XOR vはuとvのビット単位の排他的論理和を意味する。
シリーズの量子アルゴリズム部分のレッスン5と6で複数回見たものだ。これが古典的
コードが線形であることの意味だ。本質的に、長さnのバイナリ文字列をn次元ベクトルと考えている。
各エントリは0か1だが、実数や複素数上の通常のベクトル加算の代わりに、
2を法とした加算を使用している。これは単純にXORだ。つまり、
2つのコードワードuとv、つまりuとvがCにあるバイナリ文字列であれば、u + v（mod 2）、言い換えれば u XOR
vもCのコードワードでなければならない。ちなみに、この含意はUがVと等しい場合でも成り立たなければならない。
その可能性を排除するものは何もない。そして、すべての古典的線形符号はゼロのみの文字列を含まなければならないことが示される。なぜなら、
任意の文字列自身とのビット単位XORはゼロのみの文字列になるからだ。例えば、3ビット
繰り返し符号は古典的線形符号だ。特に、Uには2つの可能な選択肢があり、
Vにも2つの可能な選択肢がある。そして、ビット単位XORを取ると常にコードワードが得られることを確認するために、可能なペアを検討するのは非常に簡単だ。
XORをここで示す。別の例は、743 Hammingコードと呼ばれるものだ。これは最初の古典的誤り
訂正符号の一つで、長さ7の16個のバイナリ文字列から構成される。これらの文字列の選択には非常に単純な論理がある。
がこのビデオでは説明しない。また、これらの文字列が逆順に表記されることもあると述べておくべきだろう。
今のところ、主要なポイントは、これらの文字列のうちの2つを取ってXORすると、コードの別の文字列が得られることだ。
つまり線形符号だ。単一の角括弧内の743という表記は、前のレッスンで言及したスタビライザーコードの二重
角括弧表記に類似したものを意味する。ただしここでは古典的線形
符号のためだ。特に、コードワードは7ビットを持ち、16のコードワードがあるので4ビットをエンコードできる。
距離3の符号、つまりあるコードワードを別のコードワードに変えるには少なくとも3ビットを反転させる必要がある。
ということは、最大1ビットのビット反転誤りを訂正できる。これらは
シンプルな符号の例だが、743 Hammingコードの例でさえ、すべてのコードワードを単に列挙するだけでは謎めいて見える。だから、より良い方法が必要だ。
古典的線形符号を記述するためのより良い方法が。これを行う2つの自然な方法がある。1つの方法は、古典的
線形符号をコードを生成する最小のコードワードの集合を与えることで記述することだ。つまり、これらのコードワードのすべての可能な
部分集合を取ってXORすることで、コード全体が得られるということだ。これは数学的な用語で
画面に示されている。これを考えるもう1つの方法は、このコードをベクトル空間の部分空間として見ていることだ。この
生成元の集合はその部分空間の基底だ。算術が2を法として行われるベクトル空間であることを念頭に置いて。M個の生成元があれば、
2のM乗個の要素を持つコードが得られる。各生成元はコード内の要素の数を2倍にする。
これは、バイナリアルファベット上の古典的線形符号が常に2の累乗の数の文字列を含むという事実と一致している。
古典的線形符号を記述する2番目の自然な方法はパリティチェックによるものだ。具体的には、これはコード内の文字列と同じ長さのバイナリ文字列の最小
リストであり、コード内の文字列は、これらのパリティチェック文字列のそれぞれとのバイナリ内積がゼロになるものだ。バイナリ内積は単純に通常の
内積だ。
mod 2の内積で、これもレッスン5でクエリ
アルゴリズムの文脈で登場したものだ。パリティチェック文字列と呼ばれる理由は、ある文字列UがVとの二進内積が
ゼロになる条件が、VにおけるビットUの対応ビットが偶数パリティを持つ場合に限るからだ
古典線形符号をこのようにパリティチェック文字列の最小リストで記述するとき、各パリティ
チェック文字列は符号内の文字列数を2で割る。つまり、これら二通りの方法で記述された一つの符号に対して、m + Rは常に
nとなる。ここで重要な点は、二進内積は厳密な意味での内積ではないということだ。特に
二つの文字列の二進内積がゼロでも、通常の意味で直交していることにはならない
例えば、文字列1 1の自身との二進内積はゼロだ。つまり
このパリティチェック文字列自体が符号に含まれることもある。これは念頭に
置いておくべきことだ。例えば、すでに知っているように3ビット繰り返し符号は線形符号なので、この両方の方法で
記述できる。特に生成元として使えるのは111のみで、代わりに
この2つのパリティチェック文字列で符号を記述することもできる。これはこの符号の前の議論で見たはずだ
そして7-4-3ハミング符号については、これらの生成元とこれらのパリティ
チェックが使える。ちなみにここでは、全てのパリティチェック文字列がそれ自体符号に含まれる
古典線形符号に関する最後のコメントとして、それらをスタビライザー形式と結びつけておこう。これらのパリティチェック
文字列は、ZとIdentityのパウリ行列のみを持つスタビライザー生成元と等価だ。例えばパリティチェック
文字列1 1 0と0 1 1（3ビット繰り返し符号のもの）は、スタビライザー生成元ZZ Identityと
Identity ZZに正確に対応する。これは前の
レッスンでのこの種の観測量の議論と一致している。次にCSS符号について議論する。これはスタビライザー符号であり、符号化におけるビット数が同じある
古典線形符号のペアを組み合わせることで得られる。これは任意の二つの
古典線形符号で成立するわけではなく、後述するように二つの符号がある関係を満たす必要がある。それでもこの
構成により、75年以上の古典符号理論から学んだことをもとにした量子誤り訂正符号の可能性が大きく広がる
古典符号理論から学んだことが部分的に反映されている。スタビライザー形式において
ZとIdentityのパウリ行列のみを含むスタビライザー生成元はパリティチェックと等価だと既に述べた。例えば3ビット
繰り返し符号ではパリティチェック文字列1 1 0と0 1 1を使って、最左の2ビットが等しく
最右の2ビットも等しいことを符号内の全文字列に対して強制できる。これら2つのパリティチェック文字列はスタビライザー
生成元ZZ IdentityとIdentity ZZに正確に対応する。7-4-3ハミング符号では
これらのパリティチェック文字列を使え、それらは対応するスタビライザー生成元に対応する。1をZに、0をIdentityに置き換えればいい
ちなみにこれらのスタビライザー生成元は見覚えがあるかもしれない。7 qubit Steane符号の6つのスタビライザー生成元のうち3つだからだ
これは偶然ではなく、後ほど何が起きているか正確に説明する。Z
スタビライザー生成元という名前を、このようなスタビライザー生成元、つまりパウリZとIdentityのテンソル
因子のみを持つものに付ける。つまりZスタビライザー生成元にXとYは現れない。同様に
XとIdentityのパウリ行列のみが現れるスタビライザー生成元も考えられる。これはZスタビライザー生成元と完全に類似していると考えられる
ただしZスタビライザー生成元とは異なり、標準基底ではなくプラスマイナス基底でのパリティチェックを記述する
例えば7-4-3ハミング符号に戻ると、
7 qubit Steane符号の残りの3つのスタビライザー生成元を考えると、それらはZスタビライザー生成元と全く同じパターンに従っている
ただし今度はZの代わりにXを代入する。これら3つのスタビライザー生成元だけから得られるのは
ここに示す16の状態を含む符号だ。これはHadamard gateを7-4-3ハミング符号の文字列に対応する標準基底状態に適用して得られる
もちろん符号空間にはこれらの状態の線形結合も含まれる。当然ながらこの形式のスタビライザー生成元はXスタビライザー生成元と呼ばれる
今度はYもZも許されない。これでCSS符号を
簡潔に定義できる。CSS符号はZのみで表現できるスタビライザー符号だ
スタビライザー生成元とXスタビライザー生成元だけで表現できる。つまりYは許されず、XとZが同じスタビライザー
生成元に現れてはならない。明確にするために言っておくと、スタビライザー符号のスタビライザー生成元の選び方には自由度がある
この定義が言っているのは、CSS符号とはZとXのスタビライザー生成元だけを選ぶことが可能な符号だということだ
ただし一般にはZやXスタビライザー生成元でない別のスタビライザー生成元を選ぶこともできる
望むなら。これはCSS符号の最も単純な非自明な例だ。Zスタビライザー
生成元とXスタビライザー生成元の両方がある場合で、これが成立することの確認は一目見るだけで分かる。前の
レッスンでこれが有効なスタビライザー符号であることを知っているからだ。符号空間は1次元で、あるベクトルで張られる空間であり
five plus Belだ。スタビライザー生成元がこのベクトルに自明に作用することは、画面に示された
2つのebetの表現と、01
およびプラスマイナス基底でのパリティチェックとしてのスタビライザー生成元の解釈を考えることで分かる。7 qubit Steane符号はCSS符号のもう一つの例だ。この
生成元の選択ではZとXスタビライザー生成元しかないし、これが有効な
スタビライザー符号であることもすでに知っている。N9 qubit Short符号もまた例の一つで、今度は6つのZ
スタビライザー生成元と2つのXスタビライザー生成元がある。それで問題ない。バランスや
対称性がある必要はない。ただし実際に有効なスタビライザー符号であることが重要で、それは
各Zスタビライザー生成元が各Xスタビライザー生成元と可換でなければならないことを意味する。つまり
2種類の生成元を独立に選ぶことはできない。これについては後ほど少し詳しく述べる。次に誤り
検出と訂正について、CSS符号に対して議論する。分かることは、9 qubit Shore
符号で観察された性質、つまりX誤りとZ誤りを独立に検出・訂正できるという性質が、CSS符号全般に
成立するということだ
これをさらに説明するために、7 qubit Steane符号のようなCSS符号を考えよう。ただし別のCSS符号でも構わない
基本的な考え方は、Z安定化子生成元がXエラーを検出するということだ
ただし、Z安定化子生成元は常にZと可換なので、Zエラーに対しては完全に無感覚だ
さらに、Z安定化子生成元は、Zエラーへの補正として適用しようとするどんなZ gateとも可換だ
Zエラーへの補正についても同様で、X安定化子生成元はZエラーを検出するが、完全に
Xエラーや補正には無感覚だ。だから本質的に、Z安定化子生成元はビット反転、つまりXエラーから保護する
古典線形符号を表していると考えられる。一方、X安定化子生成元は
プラスマイナス基底における古典線形符号を表し、プラスとマイナス状態間の反転から
完全に独立して保護する。つまり位相反転エラー、すなわちZエラーだ。これでSteaneコードで何が起きているかがかなり明らかになった
これは単純に、ビット反転エラーに対する[7,4,3]ハミング符号と、位相反転エラーに対する[7,4,3]ハミング符号だ
改めて言うと、Z安定化子生成元とX安定化子生成元が可換であることが必要条件だ
それが満たされなければ有効な安定化子符号にならない。[7,4,3]ハミング符号がこのように上手くいくのは幸運とも言えるが
有効な安定化子符号を与えてくれる古典線形符号のペアには他にも多くの選択肢がある
この方法で組み合わせることで。では一般的なCSS符号に戻ろう。Z安定化子生成元が
最大J個のXエラーの訂正を可能にし、X安定化子生成元が
最大K個のZエラーの訂正を可能にするとしよう。Steaneコードの場合、JとKはどちらも1だ
なぜなら[7,4,3]ハミング符号は1つのビット反転を訂正できるからだが、一般的にJとKは異なる値になりえる
すると、エラーの離散化により、CSS符号はJとKの最小値までの
任意の個数のqubit上の任意のエラーを訂正できることが導かれる。シンドロームを測定すると、ある
個数のqubit上の任意のエラーが確率的に崩壊し、XエラーとZエラー、あるいはその両方の組み合わせになる
そしてXエラーとZエラーを独立して検出・訂正できる。だから、2つの
古典線形符号が「うまく合う」、つまりXとZの安定化子生成元が可換になるという意味で相性が良ければ
それらを組み合わせて得られるCSS符号は、基本的に2つの符号の誤り訂正特性を受け継ぐ
ただし、代償がある。2つの古典符号でビットをエンコードするほど多くのqubitはエンコードできない
なぜなら、CSS符号の安定化子生成元の総数は
2つの古典符号のパリティチェックの数の和だからで、各安定化子生成元はコード空間の次元を
半分にする。例えば、[7,4,3]ハミング符号は4つの古典ビットのエンコードを可能にする。なぜなら
この符号のパリティチェックはたった3つだからだ。一方、7-qubit Steaneコードは1つのqubitしかエンコードしない。なぜなら6つの
安定化子生成元を持つからだ。このレッスンでCSS符号全般について最後に説明するのは、CSS符号のコード空間に関することだ
コード空間がどのように見えるかで、これによって2つの
古典線形符号がCSS符号を形成するために組み合わせられる「相性が良い」という関係について、もう少し詳しく調べる機会にもなる
N個のqubit上の任意のCSS符号を考えよう。Z1からZsをZ安定化子生成元に対応するNビットの
パリティチェック文字列とする。これは、Z安定化子生成元によって記述される古典
線形符号（これをCZと呼ぼう、Z安定化子生成元に対応する符号であることを覚えるため）が
画面に示された形式を取ることを意味する。言葉で言えば、この符号は各パリティチェック文字列とのバイナリ内積がゼロになるすべての文字列Uを含む
もし望むなら、同じ文字列から派生した別の符号を考えることもできる。それをDZと呼ぼう。考え方は
Z1からZsの文字列をパリティチェック文字列としてではなく、生成元として
考えるというものだ
この時点では、なぜこの符号を考えたいのかは明確でないが、考えることはできるし、この
議論に関連してくることが分かるだろう。この符号はCZの双対符号と呼ばれ、一般的にCZ⊥と表記される。つまり垂直記号を上付きとするが
ここではDZと呼ぼう。DはDual（双対）の略なので覚えやすいはずだ
X安定化子生成元についても同様のことができる。今度はCXが、X安定化子生成元に対応するパリティチェック文字列を持つ古典線形符号で
DXはこの符号の双対符号だ。余談として、CZとCXが「相性が良い」という意味で
CSS符号として組み合わせられるために成立しなければならない条件を、これらの符号自体の観点から記述できる
具体的には、DZがCXに含まれること、あるいは同等にDXがCZに含まれることが必要だ
そして今、これら2つの符号から導かれるCSS符号のコード空間を記述することが
可能になった。一つの記述方法は、画面に示された形式のベクトルすべてが張る空間だということだ。言葉で言えば、
X安定化子生成元に対応する符号のX安定化子生成元CXの双対符号DX内の文字列上の一様重ね合わせのような形で
Z安定化子生成元に対応する符号CZ内の文字列によってシフト、つまりXORされたものだ
Steaneコードの具体的なケースでこれがどのように見えるかはすぐに見ていこう。これが意味をなすのは、コード空間内の状態がすべての安定化子生成元の
+1固有ベクトルでなければならず、特にX安定化子生成元の1つによる乗算が対応するX文字列によるXORと等価だからだ
だからこそ、異なる文字列によってシフトされたDX上のこれらの一様重ね合わせがこのような形で現れる
この表現のY文字列で表されるシフトの異なる選択が同じベクトルを与えることもある
だからこれらの状態はすべて別々というわけではないが、まとめてコード空間全体を張っている
XとZ安定化子生成元の間には対称性がある
それらが対応する符号との間にも対称性があり、その対称性を使ってXとZを入れ替える類似の方法でコード空間内のベクトルを記述できるが
標準基底もプラスマイナス基底と入れ替える必要がある。だからこの表現にアダマール演算が現れる
さて、約束していた例、つまりSteaneコードだが、これら2つのエンコードされた状態として可能なものが得られる
ゼロと1の標準基底状態のエンコードだ。特に、ゼロ状態を
[7,4,3]ハミング符号の双対符号内の8つの文字列上の一様重ね合わせとしてエンコードできる
これは[7,4,3]ハミング符号内の文字列の半分であることが分かる。そして
1状態も同様の方法でエンコードできるが、この場合はすべての文字列が全1文字列とXORされる
その文字列はたまたま743ハミングコードには含まれているが、その双対コードには含まれていないからだ。最後にもう一つ述べておくと、我々はしばしば
コード空間内のベクトルがどのようなものかをそれほど気にしない。というのも、コードを使うためにそれを知る必要は一般的にないからだ。
だから、この説明がわかりにくかったとしても、あまり気にしなくていい。ただ、CSSコードのコード空間内の
ベクトルがどのようなものかを問うのは非常に自然なことであり、この説明はその答えを与えてくれる。
次に、トーラスコードと呼ばれる特定のCSSコードについて説明する。これはトポロジカル量子誤り訂正コードとして知られるものの一例だ。
このコードはAlexa Kayvによって発見された。
1997年のことだ。実はトーラスコードは単一のコードではなく、各正整数に対して一つ存在するコードのファミリーで、
少なくとも2以上の整数に対応する。これらのコードはいくつかの重要な特性を持っている。最初の重要な特性は、
すべてのstabilizerジェネレーターがPauli演算として低い重みを持つということだ。具体的にはすべて重み4になる。
これは良いことで、各stabilizerジェネレーターの測定に関与する必要があるqubitの数が少なくて済むからだ。
量子LDPCコード、つまり量子低密度パリティチェックコードという言葉を使う人もいる。
この用語はここでいう「低」が4を意味するもので、トーラスコードは量子LDPCコードの一例だ。
トーラスコードはさらに幾何学的局所性と呼ばれる特性も持っている。これはstabilizerジェネレーターが低い重みを持つだけでなく、
qubitを空間的に配置することで、各stabilizerジェネレーターの測定が
互いに近接したqubitだけを含むようにできるということを意味する。これにより、こうした測定は原理的に実装しやすくなる。
そして最後に、これらのコードは距離が大きいため、比較的高いエラー率に耐えられる。
これらのコードがどのように機能するかを説明しよう。まず、大文字のLを2以上の正整数とし、
L×Lの格子を周期的な境界条件付きで考える。
例えば、L=8のL×L格子がある。右側と下側の線が点線になっていることに注目してほしい。
考え方としては、右側の点線を左側の線と同じ線として捉えたい。
同様に、下側の点線は上側の線と同じ線だ。
この種の構成を物理的に実現するには、3次元が必要になる。
具体的には、まず左右の辺を合わせて円柱を作り、次に端にある円、つまり格子の上下の辺だったものが
合わさるように円柱を曲げることで実現できる。あるいは
上下を先に合わせてから左右を合わせることもできる。どちらの方法でもうまくいくし、この議論においてはどちらの順でやっても構わない。
こうして得られるのがトーラス、つまりドーナツ形だ。ただし、タイヤのチューブとして考えた方が
イメージしやすいかもしれない。これはソリッドではないからだ。格子は実際にはトーラスの表面だけになった。
そしてこれがトーラスコードという名前の由来だ。このようなトーラス上での移動方法、
格子上の隣接する点間を移動できると仮定した場合、昔ながらのビデオゲームをやったことがある人にはおなじみだろう。
画面の上端を超えると下端から出てくる、左右の端も同様だ。
大部分において、三次元空間のトーラスについて具体的に語るよりも、この格子をそのように説明することにする。
次に、格子のエッジにqubitを配置することを想像しよう。
画面に示されているように、qubitは青い実線の丸で示されている。
ちなみに、点線上に配置されているqubitは実線になっていないことに気付くだろう。これはそれらのqubitがすでに
上側または左側のものとして表現されているからだ。上と左の線が点線で示された下と右の線とまったく同じ線であることを念頭に置いてほしい。
これらのqubitをすべて数えると、2×L²個のqubitが得られる。
これは、水平エッジにL²個のqubit、垂直エッジにL²個のqubitが得られることから確認できる。
これがqubitの配置だ。トーラスコード自体を説明するには、stabilizerジェネレーターを記述するだけでいい。
stabilizerジェネレーターには2種類ある。まずZのstabilizerジェネレーターがあり、
これらは図のタイルまたはプレケットに対応する。次にXのstabilizerジェネレーターがあり、
これらは図の頂点に対応する。例えば、ここに一つのstabilizerジェネレーターがある。
これはこのタイルに接しているqubitそれぞれに対してPauli Z演算を一つずつテンソル積したものと、他のすべてのqubitに対する恒等行列を合わせたものだ。
これで重み4のPauli演算が得られる。そしてここにXのstabilizerジェネレーターの例がある。
この頂点に接している4つのqubitにPauli X行列が作用し、
他のすべてのqubitには恒等行列が作用する。これも重み4のPauli演算だ。両方の
種類のstabilizerジェネレーターについて、周期的境界でラップアラウンドするものも含めることが重要だ。これはXのstabilizerジェネレーターの例だ。
有効なstabilizerコードを得るには、stabilizer
ジェネレーターが交換可能である必要がある。ZのstabilizerジェネレーターはZが自身と交換可能で恒等行列がすべてと交換可能なので、互いに交換可能だ。
XのstabilizerジェネレーターについてもXが自身と交換可能なので同様だ。また、ZのstabilizerジェネレーターとXの
stabilizerジェネレーターが互いに素なqubitの集合に対して非自明に作用する場合、つまり示されている2つのジェネレーターのように、それらは交換可能なのは明らかだ。
残りの可能性は、ZのstabilizerジェネレーターとXのstabilizerジェネレーターが重複する場合だ。
そのような場合、常に2つのqubitで重複するので、ZZとXXが交換可能であるため、stabilizerジェネレーターは交換可能だ。
これは最小のstabilizerジェネレーター集合ではない。特に、すべてのZのstabilizerジェネレーターを掛け合わせると
恒等行列が得られる。なぜなら各qubitがZによって2回掛けられるからだ。
各qubitに接する2つのタイルのそれぞれで1回ずつだ。つまり、すべてのZのstabilizerジェネレーターを一つ除いて掛け合わせると
その最後の一つが得られる。つまり独立ではないが、どれか一つを取り除けば独立な集合が得られる。
XのstabilizerジェネレーターについてもXが自身と交換可能なので同様だ。どれを取り除いても構わない。
そうすると各型からL²-1個のstabilizerジェネレーターが残る。
はっきり言っておくと、これは前回のレッスンで触れたことだが、実際にはこれらのstabilizerジェネレーターすべてを考慮しており、厳密な
操作的な意味では、各型から一つを無視するということはしない。しかし、コードを解析する目的では、
各型のstabilizerジェネレーターを一つ取り除いて最小生成集合を得ると想定できる。
これらの除去されたgeneratorの結果は、同じ種類の他のすべてのstabilizer
generator observableの結果から常に推論できることを念頭に置いておく。つまり、このcodeがエンコードするqubitの数は
qubitの総数、すなわち2 * l^2から、最小生成集合におけるstabilizer generatorの総数である2 * l^2 -
1を引いたものに等しい。つまり2 qubitをエンコードできるということだ。ちなみに、code空間が非自明であることは論じていないが、確かに
非自明であり、stabilizer generatorを掛け合わせることで
-1に単位行列を掛けた結果が得られるような方法は存在しないということを自分で確認してみてほしい。これがトーラスcode自体だ。この時点では
このcodeがなぜ量子誤り訂正に適しているのかまったく明らかではないかもしれないが、これを解析する必要があり、分かることは
実際に非常に優れた量子誤り訂正codeだということだ。トーラスcodeが量子誤り訂正codeとしてどう機能するかを理解するために
さまざまな誤りとそれが生成するシンドロームを考えることから始める。最初に注意すべきことは
トーラスcodeはCSSコードだということだ。なぜなら、すべてのstabilizer generatorはZまたはXのstabilizer
generatorのいずれかだからだ。これはつまり、X誤りとZ誤りは別々に検出・訂正できる可能性があるということを意味する。
実際、ZとXのstabilizer generatorの間には単純な対称性があり、Xの
誤りとZ誤りを本質的に同じ方法で解析できる。そのためX誤りに焦点を当てる。X誤りはZの
stabilizer generatorによって検出される可能性がある。そして、まったく同じ
アイデアを使ってX stabilizer generatorで検出される可能性があるZ誤りにすべてを置き換えることができる。以下はL
次格子の辺上にある2つの正方形qubitを示す図で、周期的境界条件を持ち、これが
トーラスの表面に配置されていると想像できる。現時点では、すべてのqubitは青で示されており、これらは影響を受けていないqubitだ。
誤りは発生していない。つまり、この時点でこれらのqubitの状態は、このcodeのcode空間にあると想像してほしい。
述べたように、焦点はX誤りに当てる。少し後で、マゼンタの円を使って
X誤りの影響を受けたqubitを示す。X誤りはZのstabilizer generatorによって検出される。これは図の
タイルに対応する。白いタイルはプラス1の測定結果、つまり
そのgeneratorに対応するシンドロームのエントリを示す。一方、灰色のタイルはマイナス1の測定
結果を示す。プラス1の結果、つまり白いタイルは、対応する
stabilizer generatorが「満足」していること、このgeneratorに関してはすべてが問題なさそうであることを示す。一方、マイナス1の結果または灰色のタイルは
対応するstabilizer generatorが「不満足」であることを示す。明らかにこの結果を引き起こす誤りが発生したはずだからだ。
現時点では、誤りは発生していないため、すべてのstabilizer generatorは満足している。z stabilizer generatorについて考えると
それが行っているのは、タイルに接触する4つのqubitの標準基底に関するパリティを測定することだけだ。
プラス1の結果はこれら4つのqubitにX誤りが発生していないことを示すのではなく、
偶数個のX誤りが発生したことを示す。一方、マイナス1の結果は
奇数個のX誤りが発生したことを示す。では、X誤りを導入して何が
起きるか見てみよう。このqubitに接触するタイルに対応する2つのZ stabilizer generatorは今や不満足だ。なぜなら、この
X誤りはこれらのgeneratorの両方と反交換するからだ。あるいは、標準基底で言えば、今は
2つのタイルに対応する4つのqubitの集合の両方が奇数パリティを持つ状態にある。これが単一の
X誤りの影響だ。このシンドロームを測定して、1つのX誤りだけが発生したと分かるか仮定すれば
どのqubitが反転したかを簡単に推論し、単純にXgateで反転させ直すことができる。では
追加のX誤りを導入するとどうなるか見てみよう。特に、別の
qubitに2番目のX誤りが発生するとどうなるか見てみよう。灰色のタイルの1つに接触するqubitで、
上の灰色のタイルのようなものだとしよう。そのタイルは今や満足している。なぜなら、このタイルに接触するqubitに2つのX誤りが発生し、2は偶数だからだ。
これら2つのX誤りは合わせてこのタイルのstabilizer generatorと可換だ。別の言い方をすれば
この2番目のX誤りは、これら4つのqubitの標準基底の状態を奇数パリティから偶数パリティへと戻した。
一方、この新しいX誤りの左のタイルは今や不満足だ。
このプロセスを続けて新しいX誤りを追加し続けることができる。隣接するとはqubitが同じタイルに接触することを意味するが、隣接するX誤りの連鎖を形成する限り
このマイナス1の測定結果を押し回すことができる。分かることは、隣接する誤りの連鎖の
端点では常にマイナス1のシンドローム測定結果が得られるということだ。つまり、端点がある限り隣接する
X誤りの連鎖は常に検出できる。ちなみに複数の連鎖があることもあるが、後で
その可能性に戻る。しかし、端点を持たない隣接するX誤りの連鎖も
あり得る。つまり、誤りの連鎖が閉じたループを形成できるということだ。さらに誤りを追加して
例えばこのように閉じたループを形成させてみよう。今や
すべてのタイルで偶数個のX誤りがあるため、すべてのstabilizer generatorは満足している。分かったことは、
隣接するX誤りの閉じたループはこのcodeでは検出されないということだ。このような場合、オール・プラス1のシンドロームが得られるためだ。
これはがっかりするように見えるかもしれない。実際、閉じたループを形成するには隣接するX誤りが4つあれば十分だ。
距離4のcodeより優れたものを期待しているのだから。しかし、一部の閉じたループの
隣接するX誤りはstabilizer自体にある。格子の各頂点にX stabilizer generatorがあることを思い出してほしい。
隣接するX stabilizer generatorを掛け合わせれば、X操作の閉じたループを形成できる。
ちょうど今ここで示したように、少し前に構築した閉じたループと同様だ。つまり、X誤りの一部の閉じたループは
実際には誤りではない。なぜなら、これらはstabilizerにあるため、code空間に何もしないからだ。しかし
stabilizerにない閉じたループのX誤りも存在する。これらはcodeで検出されない非自明な誤りを表す。
そして、さまざまな種類のループを特徴付けるかなり単純な方法がある。
格子内のすべての線、つまり上から下へのすべての垂直線とすべての水平線を
左から右へと偶数回交差するループは、常にX stabilizer generatorの積だ。これには画面上の例も含まれる。
また、周期的境界を越える可能性を含む、より複雑なループも含まれるが
しかし、これらのX誤りの閉じたループにX stabilizer generatorを掛け合わせることで、実質的に縮小して
消してしまうことができる。ちなみに、X stabilizer generatorを掛け合わせることでしかこういったループが得られないのはまったく正しい。なぜならすべてのX stabilizer
generatorはすべての水平線と垂直線に対して偶数個のX演算を配置するからだ
もう一種類の閉じたループは、ある線を少なくとも1回奇数回横切るものだ。例えば
ここに示したもので、すべての水平線をちょうど1回横切る。そしてもう一つの例として
各垂直線をちょうど1回横切るものがある。これらはcodeで検出されない非自明な誤りの例だが、重要な
点は、このような閉じたループを形成する唯一の方法は、トーラスを一周することだ。つまり穴の
中を通るか、穴を貫くか、あるいはその両方だ。これはトポロジー的な性質
であり、トーラスに関するものだ。基本的にはすべて穴に関係していて、それがこれをtopological Quantum error correcting
codeと呼ぶ理由だ。周期的境界を持つ2次元格子の可視化という観点では、このカテゴリのchainは
周期的境界の一方または両方をループするものでなければならず、そのループをX stabilizer generatorで縮小することが不可能な形で
点に収束できないものだ。そのようなchainはここで示したものより
複雑になる場合もあるが、これが取りうる最短のループだ。なぜなら何らかの形で周期的境界の
一方または両方をループしなければならないからだ。そしてこれが意味するのは、非自明な
検出不可能な誤りの最小重みはLだということだ。それより少ない誤りを持つ閉じたループはすべて最初のカテゴリに入り、したがって
stabilizerに属する。閉じたループを形成しない誤りのchainはcodeによって検出される。これが全てだ。これがこのcode
が機能する理由だ。そして最終的に得られるのは[[2L², 2, L]] stabilizer codeだ。2L²個の
qubitを使って2つのqubitを符号化し、codeの距離はLになる。次にToric codeでの
誤り訂正についてごく簡単に触れるが、詳細には踏み込まない。syndromeを測定して
全て+1のsyndromeでない結果が出た場合、ここではZ stabilizer generatorについてだけ話しているが
-1の結果は隣接するX誤りのchainの端点を示していて、それらを訂正しようと試みることができる
-1の結果を対にして、その間にX訂正のchainを形成することで。そして
これを行う際には、訂正のための最短経路を選ぶのが理にかなっている。例えば
ここに示すようなsyndromeを測定した場合、不満なタイル間のこの経路を選んでXを適用する
gateをこの経路に沿って訂正として適用できる。もちろんsyndromeを引き起こした実際の誤りのchainは
ここに示すような別のものだった可能性もある。しかしそれで構わない。誤りと訂正が合わせて
stabilizerに入る限りは。また訂正がトーラスを周回するループを完成させてしまう可能性もある
これは悪いことで、そうすることで論理的な誤りを引き起こしたことになる。つまりこの最短経路に沿って訂正するという戦略は
低重みの誤りは訂正できるが、高重みの誤りに対しては機能しないかもしれない。しかしもちろん
どんなQuantum error correcting codeに対してもそれ以上を期待することはできない。おそらくノイズモデルによるが
syndromeで多数の-1を観測する場合があって、この場合は効率的な古典アルゴリズムを使って
それらを対にして、前のレッスンで述べたようにsyndromeを表す最小重み誤りを見つけることができる
これは常にsyndromeの最も可能性が高い説明を訂正するわけではないが、一般的にはかなりうまく機能する
そして距離Lの半分未満の重みを持つ誤りを常に正しく訂正できる。また
異なる誤りモデルに対してより適した他の戦略もあることを述べておく。Toric codeが発見されてから25年以上が経ち
その間にQuantum error correcting codeに関してかなりの研究が行われてきた。これには
Toric codeに触発されたother topological Quantum error correcting codeや、異なる
考え方に基づくcodeも含まれる。既知のすべての異なるcode構成の包括的なリストを提供することは当然できないが、少し表面をかすめて
よく知られた例をいくつか簡単に触れる。まず実は
Toric codeが周期的境界を持つことは本質的に必要ではない。つまり、Toric codeの一部を切り取って
トーラスではなく2次元平面に平らに展開することが可能で、そうすることで得られるのをsurface
codeと呼ぶ。例えば、ここに示すパターンで格子の端を切り取ると、いわゆるrough edgeが
上下にあり、smooth edgeが側面にあり、stabilizer generatorのedge caseも対応して含めると
今度は1つのqubitしか符号化できないcodeが得られる。しかしそれでもこのcodeはToric codeの最も
重要な特性を引き継いでいる。特にこのcodeの非自明な検出不可能な誤りは
左端から右端へ、または上から下へ伸びる誤りのchainに対応しなければならない
X誤りのchainかZ誤りのchainかによって異なる。また辺を斜めに切ることも可能で
それによってrotated surface codeと呼ばれることもあるものが得られ、そうすることはcodeを
使用するqubit数の観点でより経済的にするのに役立つ。例えばこのsurface
codeを取って一部のqubitを捨てて、対角線方向に向いた正方形を残すと、別のsurface
codeが得られる。境界のstabilizer generatorを正しい方法で指定する限り。このような図は
stabilizer generatorがどのように定義されているかを明確にするのに役立つ。黒いタイル（端の丸みを帯びたものも含む）はX stabilizer
generatorを示し、白いタイルはZ stabilizer generatorを示す。境界のものはちなみに、今度は単なる2 qubit XXまたは
ZZ stabilizer generatorだ。そしてこれらの図が45°回転した形でよく見られる
もう一つの興味深いcodeのクラスで、topological codeの一般的なカテゴリにも含まれるのがcolor
codeだ。どのように機能するかは詳しく説明しないが、考え方の一つは7 qubit Steane codeの幾何学的な一般化だということだ
では7 qubit Steane codeを考えて、qubitにKCET順序付け規則を使って番号を付けるとしよう
ここに示すように。そうするとこれら7つの
qubitをここに示すグラフの頂点と関連付けることができ、stabilizer generatorがグラフの辺によって形成される
タイルまたは面と対応していることがわかる。各タイルに対して常にZ stabilizer
generatorとX stabilizer generatorがあり、そのタイルの頂点にあるqubitにのみ非自明に作用する
これは便利だ。トーラコードと同様に、このコードには幾何学的局所性があるから、
stabilizer generatorを測定するためにqubitを長距離移動させる必要がない。そして、ZとXのstabilizer generatorが常に非自明な作用をする
qubitの集合がまったく同じであるという事実も、fault tolerant量子計算に関連した理由で都合がいい。これについては
次のレッスンで詳しく述べる。カラーコードとは、この
基本的なパターンを一般化した量子誤り訂正コードだ。本質的に同じことをするが、異なるグラフを使う。例えば、これは
19頂点のグラフで、これが機能する。これにより、1 qubitを19 qubitにエンコードするコードが得られ、
距離は5になる。これらはカラーコードと呼ばれているが、その理由は、グラフに課される必要条件の一つが、面が三色彩色可能であること、つまり
3色で面を塗り分けられ、同じ色の面が辺を共有しないようにできるからだ。
色はコード自体には実際には関係ない。色に関係なく各面に対してXとZのstabilizer generatorがあるだけだ。しかし、色は
動作の解析において重要になる。以上が非常によく知られた2つの
コードファミリーだが、他にも多くの構成が知られている。これらのコードファミリーと類似したアイデアに基づくものも、
まったく異なるものもある。最近発見された量子誤り訂正コードの具体的な例として、
IBMの同僚たちが発見したgross codeと呼ばれるものがある。grossとはダースの
ダース、つまり144のことだからそう名付けられた。特に、このコードは12 qubitを144 qubitにエンコードし、
距離は12だ。このコードの仕組みを詳しく説明はしないが、トーラコードに似ていて、各
stabilizer generatorが少し離れた2つの追加qubitを含む点が異なる。surface codeのような
平面埋め込みはないが、いわゆるbaner埋め込みを持つ。つまり、1層ではなく2層のqubitが必要になる。
これはbivariate bicycle codesと呼ばれるコードファミリーに属し、このファミリーの特に注目すべき点は、
トーラコードやsurface codeよりもはるかに効率的だということだ。より多くのqubitをエンコードできる一方で、
同程度のエラー率に耐えられる。gross codeではシンドローム測定のために追加で144 qubitが必要なので、
必要なqubitの総数は288になる。これにより、今日の
技術にとって非常に有望な候補となっている。以上でこのレッスンを終わる。CSSコード、トーラコード、そして
surface codeやカラーコードを含む他の量子コード構成の概観など、量子誤り訂正コードの構成について学んできた。ぜひ
このシリーズの最後のレッスン、fault tolerant量子計算に参加してほしい。エラーが発生しやすい操作と計算コンポーネントを使って、
エンコードされた量子状態上で計算を実行するという課題に取り組む。
それではまたお会いしましょう。